الحرب التجاريه هي اذا مستمره بين واشنطن
وبيجين وربما بحده اكبر الان في ساحه
التكنولوجيا
بقرار من السلطات الامريكيه بات محظورا
استيراد المعدات وخدمات الاتصالات التي
تقدمها خمس شركات صينيه بينها هواوي
لقواعد مماثله
وكذلكتا
التاني تقدمان معدات مراقبه بالفيديو
والتكنولوجيا الرقميه اضافه الى شركه هتلر
المتخصصه في معدات الراديو والاتصالات
تشير الهيئه الامريكيه لتنظيم الاتصالات
الى ان تلك الشركات تشكل تهديدا غير مقبول
للامن القومي للولايات المتحده
لكنها لا تضع الخطوه في سياقها ليست تنافس
بجديد ولا هي سياسه الاجراءات العقابيه
الذي اتبعتها اداره دونالد ترامب السابقه
فقد حضرت عام 2019 معدات هواوي وخدماتها
وقطعتها عن نظام اندرويد التابعي لجوجل
لكن دون ان يصل القرار الى حد الحظر التام
في الولايات المتحده والان تبدو اداره
الرئيس الديمقراطي
كانما تكمل حرب سلفه التجاريه على الصين
بل تراها تتخذ موقفا حازما تجاه مصنعين
معدات الاتصالات الصينيين ممن تشتبه في
انهم يتجسسون لصالح سلطان
للدواعي الامنيه عينها منعت اخيرا تدفق
تكنولوجيا الرقائق الالكترونيه عاليه
التقنيه الى الاسواق الصينيه
فحرمتها بذلك من مكون مهم لشبكات اتصالات
الجيل الخامس ثم تاتي الحمله الاحداث على
شركات التكنولوجيا الصينيه العملاقه لتول
هيبا اكثر الحرب التجاريه بين اكبر
اقتصادين في العالم
التعريفات الجمركيه وتايوان والملكيه
الفكريه والامن السيبراني وغيرها من
القضايا الخلافيه ابدت قيمته جوبادل على
هامشي قمه العشرين الاخيره الرغبه في
تفادي تحولها الى ساعه
واشنطن تتحدى محاوله التقارب تلك بمواصله
ما تدعوه تاسيس قضايا التكنولوجيا
والتجاره
اما الامريكيون سيشهرون مبررات تحركها
الهواجس الامنيه في المقام الاول وبين
الموقفين يقف خبراء ممن يقلقهم الصراع
التقني قد يكون محددا حاسما لنفود السياسي
والاقتصادي والعسكري لكنه في نظرهم لن يمر
بدون خسائر كبيره للطرفين وللعالم باكمله